if he said like in 2010 this is supposed
to happen it didn't happen that would
discredit him yeah he said when Muhammad
made that prediction
he said no prediction could have been
more unbelievable than that stuff it's
like someone saying that this guy in the
third round he's gonna tap armlock I
think this is this guy this guy the law
of probability would catch up with you
if you're guessing the law of
probability now I mean it's just like if
you're just gambling about what's gonna
happen tomorrow you know sooner or later
you're gonna have more guesses wrong
than right yeah he's not speaking in
riddles he wasn't speaking like in in
Hin algorithms or like any way that's
mystified the way some people do no sir
Thomas and such precisely and so this is
not the work of a psychic this is not
the work of a trickster is someone who's
making claims about the future over and
over and over and over and over again in
a way that is very explicit and weird
it's very specific there now are now
competing and who's gonna have the
tallest building is it gonna be the
bullish shot we're gonna power this
building right now well you talk about
we don't talk about this much but this
would be more authentic than Jesus's
miracles yeah because it is traceable
yeah why so you have like 1,400 people
in the courtroom they don't know each
other or they were there to witness and
they're all saying the same thing this
man is the one who did it
this meal a company like a cellar Malik
Oh
greetings a piece how you doing how you
been how's it going Sheikh Mohammed
alright now how's everything hummed in
lines all good hanging in there more
blessed than we realized yeah yeah hum
didn't love about the last and final
messenger sent to mankind Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon I
think any Christian any Jew any person
who went away from religion altogether
because it just didn't make sense he saw
or she saw that this is man's
fingerprints all over it the things that
you talked about are you talking about
the miracles the prophecies you know
things that any person just using the
common sense that they have they have a
little bit of insight they look at all
of these things there's no way that
these things could have could have come
to fruition and unless this this was
from the divine so I wanted you told you
yeah they're just it's amazing so let's
uh I wanted to share with the audience
some of these prophecies that prophet
mohammed peace as a Muslim upon that you
talked about and then people can also go
and read more about him in detail for
referring to is the fifth of six
currently seven they will be in shava
and total publications released by the
Athenian Institute for Sonic research on
the proofs of prophethood series we
spoke about some of the prophecies and
some of the historical factors that made
him God sending him God sending a
prophet absolutely necessary the second
paper was on the character of the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him being very contrary to the
claim that he was a liar he was an
imposter he was someone deluded into
thinking that he was a prophet so his
character was exceptional characters of
the proof so his prophethood than his
message is reflecting on the substance
the the thoroughness the the harmony the
the fruitfulness of his message that was
the third piece the fourth piece were
his achievements is the most achieved
human being in the history of the human
race
according to even non-muslim historians
who are being fair and
held back by their I guess prejudices
and this is the fifth paper on
prophecies the six was on physical
miracles along vector prophecies we
basically tried to frame out how the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him spoke about countless incidents
of the future foretold future events in
a way that just doesn't add up
to any other answer but the fact that
God was disclosing to him for his
legitimacy to add credibility in the
eyes of his audience that this man was
not speaking on his own accord because
what he was saying
number one were many things and so the
law of probability would catch up with
you if you're guessing the law of
probability now I mean it's just like if
you're just gambling about what's gonna
happen tomorrow you know sooner or later
you're gonna have more guesses wrong
than right yeah and the second and the
second issue is he's not speaking in
riddles he wasn't speaking like in in
Hin algorithms or like anyway that's
mystified doing some people do know sir
Dominus and such precisely and so this
is not the work of a psychic this is not
the work of a trickster this is someone
who's making claims about the future
over and over and over and over and over
again in a way that is very explicit and
worried it's very specific and so how do
you keep doing that over and over and
over again
now you mentioned over and over and over
if there's one thing that didn't come
true or if there's something that's
clearly that now it didn't happen and
it's put like that if he said like in
2010 this is supposed to happen it
didn't happen that would discredit him
yeah and that's actually one of the
things that I would even add to the list
of prophecies is the fact that no one
will be ever ever be able to know when
the hour is when the day of judgement is
many people trip themselves up they shot
themselves in the foot effusive if you
will by saying the hour the and they the
final day the day of judgment is on this
date and this year not only that he
never do that what he told us that even
the prophets don't know that
and lo and behold right everyone has
ever made these claims has basically the
legitimize their own call by by trying
to pull that off so give us some of
these I mean there's so many let me make
just one more disclaimer quickly before
we jump into them and that is if someone
as you said is using their common sense
they will realize what we said this is
no sidekick this is no guessing game and
the only thing they can say after that
if they're using their common sense but
how do I know he really said these
things and for that we tell people you
should give yourself a moment to
understand that we have a very rigorous
science discipline in Islam for
verifying the reports that have been
transmitted to us from our Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him from the
first Muslim community traceability is
huge for us we don't take things just
based on hearsay we don't take things
based on conflicting reports even we
don't take things without knowing who
handed them to us everything needs to be
verifiable and so that's important as
well the issue is it's called tomato
tomahto is the highest rate of
authenticity in that tradition that
discipline I'm talking about when
there's abundant concurrence statement
after statement generation after
generation these words are being relayed
in a way that if it wasn't from a common
source it would have conflicted the
playing telephone game with a pattern so
this is for sure confirmed traceable
that the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him said these things
or at least many of them there's no
doubt about that no doubt about that so
for example the Quran the Quran that he
brought to the world is related to the
world by abundant concurrence meaning
this was not a government institution
that issued a book that said that the
Prophet said no it wasn't a closed-door
project this is people that learn this
Quran went back to their own towns
you can't retrieve it again and yet 1400
years later it still matches so let's
talk about the Quran one prophecy in the
Quran the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him recited to the
world a chapter called the chapter of
the Romans the Byzantines a room in that
chapter
a lot of mighty says honey little room
Rome has been Byzantium has been eastern
Rome has been defeated in the lowest
land and they will be after their defeat
victorious in bilberry seen in three to
nine years the word builder in the
Arabic language means three to nine
years Edward Gibbon actually who's not
very fond of Islam at all by the way in
his famous book he's a huge scholar in a
story on the Roman Empire he has a a
seminal work or a great work on called
the the fall the decline and fall of the
Roman Empire
he said when Mohammed made that
prediction
he said no prediction could have been
more unbelievable than that one he said
because the first 12 years of Heracles
his reign directly is the head of the
Byzantines at the time was clearly I'm
now saying the end of the Empire it was
over like the Persians had done a number
on them the Byzantium was about to tap
out no one would have ever thought that
correctly I should have been able to
regroup gather them spearhead right into
the Persian Empire and and give them a
devastating blow and win back the way
the Koran said he would win back in such
a short period of time who would know
something like this the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him is not even connected
with those lands the Prophet Muhammad
SAW Allah said even if he was he's not
aware of their you know their vitality
even if he was he cannot determine how
long it's gonna be even if he could
determine it he's making a determination
that no one would have agreed with right
and it came out to be true within less
than ten years
Byzantium made its comeback against the
Persian Empire so how can you relate it
to now people can understand going from
a time way back some people can't relate
but today in modern day time what
example can you give Soviet Union a
superpower let's say some some some
civilization that is just totally just
almost forgotten about is about to make
a comeback that people will start
laughing at you yeah what modern day
think that we can actually I'll connect
it with another prophecy in
incidents when when the the on the
ground tangibly speaking in terms of the
the worldly what we can identify and
evaluate salaam had its back to the wall
there was so many times when the Muslims
were being persecuted then no one knew
if Islam had a tomorrow or not or they'd
be wiped out today yeah in those moments
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
said that Islam would become globalized
he said God has promised to fulfill this
mission and there will not be a house in
the eastern most or Western most parts
of the world accept that Islam will
enter it like who would have ever
thought like that is like the equivalent
of as a friend of mine once jokingly
said two guys chasing each other with
Spears in the middle of the jungle
somewhere in in Africa or Brazil and
when one of them jumps on the other and
is about to kill him he says listen if
you let me go I promise next year you're
gonna be riding and I don't know
Vladimir Putin or yeah Donald Trump's
limousine like what who where does it
the prophet sallallaahu I am at a time
when his lambs
existence seemed in peril said it and
become the most dominant the most
pervasive religion on the face of the
earth fastest-growing religion on the
face of the earth he mentioned all these
things is this also now considered a
prophecy when they were digging the
trench
you also mentioned this one though yeah
yeah and then can you relate that is
that this is also predicting something
the future it's gonna happen the Muslims
were starving and they were stuck in the
trench surrounded by ten thousand of
their enemy an army of that size had
never United on a common cause they were
United on that date to eradicate Islam
and the Muslims and as they were
scrambling to dig this trench they God
came across a huge boulder they couldn't
get past they called the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
to consult him what is happening and so
he said wait bring me the ax and he went
himself and he kept striking at it and
saying Allah is the most great I've been
given the keys meaning my nation me I've
been granted the opportunity of entering
these lands and he mentioned Rome he
mentioned Persia
he mentioned Yemen
and again this is like what is Arabia
Arabia is a dot that is invisible on the
map surrounded by endless desert planet
Earth was shared by two two empires
Roman Persia
right to say that is just inconceivable
came to head came true yeah you know and
it's not like any of these didn't come
true or any of these things were wrong
every time he said things of this nature
they became true and it wasn't just
about the spread of Islam it was even
about which individuals would play which
roles even now the roles that they were
play when they went into these lands
this was mentioned yeah I mean
subhanAllah one time when the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
was at the house of Omaha ombudsmen Hahn
who is his aunt through nursing because
of the women that that nursed him one of
their relatives so he she's his aunt
through nursing he slept in her home and
he was shown a vision about the future
of Islam and and the Muslim forces that
went out to the world to liberate the
world order or would do so at the time
that he spoke this he's he said to her I
have been seen a seen a fleet of myeloma
the first Navy fleet of the Ummah they
are forgiven God will grant them
forgiveness for embarking on the seas on
this noble mission for I think you know
the just war in the course of justice to
liberate people from these tyrannies and
she said I wish I could be with them he
said you will be a will be among them
and you know even Hajj out of the the
the comments on slidable Claddagh he
says there's so many prophecies and
better than him saying you will be among
them number one he's telling her that
you're gonna live for her until you see
this time and that Islam will also live
and that during her lifetime for the
first time ever the Muslim community
will ride the seas right and that she
also he foretold that she would die on
that mission and how would she die when
women don't come back but all of these
things converging and lo and behold she
did marry a man and she went to
accompany him on this campaign it's
expedition and on the way back she fell
off her horse and she
her neck she actually broke her neck and
she died a Mart for having left her home
for that noble cause and so all of these
things became true exactly the perfect
moment said it peace be upon his be upon
him and this is all built on a
believable message that he came to
convey to humanity just like Jesus Moses
Abraham all the other messengers to
worship the One God alone to do good
deeds to be morally upright so this is
something already resonates with the
human being and now there's evidence and
evidence and we're not even talking
about you know you mentioned one there's
the the amazing Quran that we have a
living miracle now we're in greatest
America that's the greatest miracle but
now we're going above and beyond let's
cover these there's a lot more I'm going
to throw at you you can go over them
quickly so we're gonna cover more and
then we'll direct people that if they
want more to get more into it to read
some of your articles you have the
situation where there's a bounty hunter
going after the problem Hamid peace and
buster's be upon him for what reason
because he's calling people just to
worship God he's with Abu Bakr Siddiq
right his companion yes they were
escaping the persecution of Mecca yeah
I'm sort of pneumatic at the time was a
man who needed the money so he accepted
the offer and he was a month like he's
like that guy what's the guy in Hawaii
with the blond hair
no he was the guy bounty hunter you guys
so he's a bounty hunter he's going to
get his money he's got to catch them
he's got a capture he's a professional
yes yeah and so so rock company Malik
when he finally caught up to the trail
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him and Abu Bakr is his right hand man
he was not his horse stop gaining on
them and he found that the the the hind
legs of his horse had sunk into the
scent and he realized something very
abnormal was happening here quick Sam
ultimately God was protecting his
prophet peace and blessings be upon him
and so the Prophet Muhammad said to him
why are you doing this he said o
Muhammad like it's nothing personal I
got debts I gotta pay and like I gotta
get paid don't take this personally and
he said to him go back and you will be
paid Allah will repay you you will one
day whether you believe it or not be
wearing the bracelets of caseros or
Xerxes however it's pronounced and this
is just also like what do you mean I'm
gonna be
the bracelets of the head of the Senate
version Empire the man who nobody comes
in here the man whose Empire broke
Byzantium were a bunch of like feudal
tribes amongst one another at each
other's throats
you know we muster up an army of a
hundred people to fight off a hundred
people how can this ever be and shortly
after that had the Prophet Muhammad
peace blessings be upon him and I will
buck it Allah allowed ornamental table
to be of those who liberated those lands
and saw rocks I in fact he was wearing
those traces of being called forward and
he made Soraka receive that so the
people would know the party fulfill the
prophecy only speaks the truth yeah so
this is God this is a man trying to get
his money he's on his tail the horse
starts sinking like sink quick say again
he keeps going again and then he just
couldn't and he realized also that this
is something's there's some intervention
here going on so that was divine
intervention we covered that one I want
people to play a game here red and green
red is is something he predict and
didn't happen you would put it in the
red pile Green is we got another one
over here
on the right of a proper prediction
something that came true let's talk
about the prophecy that Prophet Muhammad
now these are better ones in the desert
barefoot he talks about and they'll be
competing for building the tallest
buildings yeah many people may not know
that we believe in the Archangel Gabriel
peace and blessings be upon him who came
to teach the world through the prophets
the message of God he was the messenger
to the messengers he was God's trustee
in the heavens who delivered the message
to God trustees on earth if you will he
came to the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him one day to ask him
some questions so that he would answer
in a way that would educate the people
and so of what he asked them is when is
the hour when will the hour the last day
commenced he said to him the one that's
being asked meaning me the Prophet
Muhammad doesn't know any more than the
one asking nobody knows this no prophet
no angel and though they didn't know yet
that he was the angel he said to him
then at least tell me some of its signs
they said of its signs that a woman will
give birth to her master
which has been widely interpreted as
rebellious nests among children with
their parents the tables get flipped
respecting seniority and elderly the
elderly would begin to vanish from you
know the dominant culture then he said
and you will see a shitty naked barefoot
shepherds of sheep sheep Shepherds
competing in the construction of
high-rises of skyscrapers of tall
buildings and this is something that
could have happened with just the the
eruption of wealth eruption of resources
in many different places and times but
the most obvious manifestation of this
is what we see in the Arabian Gulf right
now yeah
overnight they discovered they're
sitting on a treasure right black gold
and petroleum and all of a sudden you
see these people who were desert
dwellers you know very desert tea
lifestyle people shepherds so many of
them almost like limited in that sense
they're now are now competing and who's
gonna have the tallest building is it
gonna be the Buddhist shop we're
proudest building right now as far as I
know it's the belief its outright in
debate debate right right and then who's
the high rises but there are other one
now that's competing with it supposed to
be in Saudi
someone's trying to outdo it they're
gonna keep trying now so this is a
fulfillment of the prophecy yes yeah
moving on another one paraphrasing the
the situation where they'll come a time
where the Muslims will end up writing in
somewhat like a box from their homes to
the mosques which is kind of a
prediction of a vehicle car yes the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him he made several prophecies
about what message it houses of worship
will look like and how we will interact
with them of them is that they will be
less frequently visited and that is an
unfortunate reality of the secular age
the
you come to God when you want not when
he wants and also he mentioned that
people will be dropping off their
womenfolk at the doors of mess of doors
of temples of houses of worship and some
narrations mentioned in revealing
clothing the unfortunate permissiveness
in attire the hyper sexuality in general
that exists in our age is certainly a
manifestation of that oh this could be
of the prophecy there's a category of
prophecy that the scholars say could be
recurrent could happen over and over
again because history repeats itself and
the human experience constantly cycles
and he also mentioned that people will
ornament their mosques and it's
mind-boggling but it's as if he didn't
say it yeah you see they'll do it we see
how and the ornament thing the mosque is
not because you're supposed to leave the
mosque shabby the mosque is supposed to
be classy and elegant but the interior
of the mosque the prayer space of the
mosque is supposed to be elegant but
simple because this is not a place where
you're supposed to be you know taking in
the scenes is when you're supposed to be
looking inward not outward yes and so
the distractions shouldn't be there the
outside of the mosque the social hall
whatever may be there can be more
flexibility there but the issue of
people boasting with the construction of
the places of humility the
contradictions and they like inverted
understanding religious understanding
was something he foretold as well about
the end times now are there certain
individuals would this also be
considered that that he mentioned in
such-and-such battle that these people
would be killed and then lo and behold
certain individuals yeah I mean these
are just like too many to count like if
you really think about it living with
him was a generation that heard so many
of these from him
that you're imagining a group of people
believers in him were walking planet
Earth knowing how their lives would
unfold and how their journey in this
life would end and so when he was
walking with Abu Bakr and Omar an earth
man who in that order would be his
successors he climbed the mountain the
mountain in outside of Medina and or
hood trembled beneath their feet and so
he said to it be calm or there's a
highly traceable narration again be calm
or be firm or hoed be stable because
upon you as a prophet referring to
himself and a Saudi of a confirmer of
truth which is the highest level of
faith I confirm er of truth which was
Abu Bakr who is known as a so dear that
was his his title that everyone knew and
up and he said and two martyrs for
telling that Omar and Othman will both
die martyrs and they both did but it
wasn't just them are martyred knee acid
may Allah be pleased with him the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him said the transgressing party
will be the one that kills you and this
is a very interesting narration because
when there happens some like political
turmoil after the fourth successor of
the Prophet or during the the reign of
the fourth successor of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
the one who fought alongside Ayane the
fourth successor a lovely pleased with
them all against the the opposition the
party that was led by Muhammad lovely
pleased with him as well we believe that
they were all intending on the truth and
seeking what's right but there was foul
play from double agents among them that
were trying to stir up discord and so
what happened was a mod with the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
foretold would be killed by the
transgressing party was killed in a
battle between these two groups the
interesting part is many of the those on
the opposition came to their senses and
said we must be transgressors we must be
wrong in this feud because the Prophet
Muhammad said we will the transgressing
party will kill our mouths and so we
killed him
the interesting thing is they didn't say
the Prophet didn't say that
they didn't say no no no that's a
made-up narration just to get political
leverage between the fight they owned
the fact that the Prophet said this
which goes against the theory that
people were making up these stories
after the fact right even like the
narration that would almost indict them
they still accepted yes the Prophet
Muhammad said this and they tried to to
interpret it in a way that would allow
them to still take the stance they made
when it didn't deny the narration in
fact right before that battle they saw
Ahmad smiling and I said why are you
smiling
he said because my beloved my prophet
said to me my last share of this world
the last like ounce of sustenance I will
have in this world will be a jug of milk
and he was watching the jug of milk
amongst the combatants be passed around
from man to man so he knew his day had
come and it's not just a bucket it's not
just their own water it's not just earth
man it's not just I'm not endless our
own what himself actually said that
right before we encountered the very
first battle in time of the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
in the battle of bed there he said the
day we found that army was in front of
us we weren't prepared to fight we were
basically caught off guard there's a
thousand nine hundred to a thousand of
them the scouting reports were saying
were three hundred and sixteen or
seventeen we don't have artillery we
don't have one horse we don't have no
nights no arm or nothing just are the
the swords we keep handy in case we
encounter a wolf on the road or
something the Prophet Mohammed reassured
them and said Allah has written victory
for you and he said to them I swear
so-and-so
one of the staunchest enemies will fall
right there he said the Prophet Muhammad
would walk over and say and that other
guy will fall right here and he would
kneel and point to the exact spot on the
ground where these people would die
tomorrow and he said every single one of
them fell the next day in no other place
than the place the Prophet had appointed
you keep saying tap it meant reminds me
of people watching this UFC and all this
stuff it's like someone saying that this
guy in the third round he's gonna tap
armlock I think this is this guy this
guy this round he's going to tap this is
bigger than that
yeah
this is an open field spending a gauge
on or something right this is like
between two mountains how do you account
for all the variables when you're not
even expected to win the fight to begin
we've got another another beam going in
the green yeah they're all in the yeah
we're we just hope people will his uh
his uh his didn't he also predict his
his uh daughter's death not so in the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him spinal sickness I should his
wife who was caring for him she said his
daughter felt Anna walked in and he said
to welcome my daughter and she walked
towards him
I assure the wife is saying she walks
just like her father may the peace of
blessings be upon them all and so she
got to her father's side and he
whispered in her ear and she began to
weep and then he whispered in her ear
again and she began to laugh and so I
actually the wife is saying it was so
odd I've never seen someone cry and
laugh so closely together and so
ultimately I assure could not bear to
not know what was said so she said to
her what did the Prophet tell you and
she said I would never disclose the
secret of The Messenger of Allah peace
and blessings be upon him she said but
when the Prophet Muhammad be some
blessings we fought and died basically
Feltham I felt it was alright at that
point to disclose it it was no longer
confidential and she said what my father
said to me the first time is that your
father will not rise from the sickness
peace and blessings be upon him says so
I wept and he said to her like are you
not satisfied that you will be the queen
of the women of paradise in the
hereafter and you will be the first of
my household to catch up with me meaning
to pass away and meet me in the
hereafter be reunited with me she said
so I laughed like it brought me great
joy and again this is not a prophecy
this is two prophecies they're very
amazing because the Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him became
sick many times in his life he never
said I will not rise from the sickness
it was the one sickness that he would
not rise from that he said I will not
rise from
and the second prophecy in in that
statement is the fact that he said that
his daughter fought on it would be the
first person in his household to die
after him and this is also very odd
because she was 20 or 22 years old and
no one thought she would die that young
and she died six months after him peace
and blessings be upon them the family
members in the household of the
messenger of allah salam Livadia said no
in fact the narrator of this incident
Aisha the wife of the Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him she has
another narration highly authentic in
Swahili Bukhari and Muslim both
confirmed in both most authentic
collections of hadith prophetic
traditions she said one time earlier
it's an earlier incident we asked the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him which
one of your wives will meet you first it
just keeps going now keeps getting
better so he he said to her after one
who couldn't I add that the one that has
the longest arm literally I'm
translating it literally she says so
when the Prophet peace and blessings be
upon him died we were all so eager to
rejoin him and so we would literally
measure our arms against one another on
the wall to see who had a longer arm she
says and Sawada
she was the tallest of them had the
longest arm she had the longest arm so
we were expecting her to die first
but when Zainab died first we realized
that by the longest arm he meant it
figuratively the one that reaches the
farthest was their charities and zeyneb
was a craftswoman she would make things
with her hand and sell them so basically
she was a businesswoman she sold her
crafts and so she had income and so she
was able to donate more than others
peace and blessings so much more let's
let's let's finish with this as a bonus
and for any person who's sincere genuine
looking for the truth I don't think
where are you gonna go when you hear all
this I mean we often also I'll just add
this as a bonus people I mean this is
confirmed in the Quran the miracles that
Jesus peace be upon him did we love him
we revere here as one of the mightiest
messengers ever sent
at his time for the people at that time
Moses for the people at that time
Abraham for his people they all came
with that same message worship the
Creator not the creation Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
is a messenger for you even if you hate
Muslims you hate Islam now there were
many at that time o martyr the allahu
allah they will only lead they were anti
islam right
they were Slavic folks right but they
became Muslims one of the great Giants
and you could too if you're sincere and
you're someone who is genuinely looking
for the truth and now you're watching
this
people often flaunt you talked about
this also about the miracles of Jesus
and all of these things you cannot
substantiate but you had the motto out
that hadith explained that and just
quickly go over where Prophet Muhammad
we talked about prophecies but just in a
few prophecies worth it's just
inconceivable that you have how many 50
60 how many people are actually
witnessing this that it's just too
outlandish to think that this is just
something made up explain that where the
feeding of so many people the the water
coming from the well you talk about we
don't talk about this much but this
would be more authentic than Jesus's
miracles yeah because it is traceable
yeah I mean the fact that the Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
perform physical miracles is not
something that was relayed to us by the
testimony of a narrator like it's not
one per maybe particular individual
miracles were narrated to us by a few
number of people but the idea that the
concept of him performing physical
miracles this was relayed to us conveyed
to us generation upon generation we know
exactly who was there exactly who said
it exactly who heard it from the person
who first said it and then there's the
issue of my cross-referencing they are
all saying the same thing and these
people disagreed on so many things but
this one thing they did not disagree on
no one ever objected or lied or said you
were at loosen anything or you were like
interpolating adding to the story or no
one ever said how many people could have
been there to witness one one or two or
any of these countless
yeah I mean Jabbar Allah be pleased with
him and others say we were 500 on that
day or we were 400 on that day where we
were 1,400 on that day we ran out of
food and the Prophet Muhammad said bring
your food so that we all had like tiny
bits of rations you know the amount that
would that would basically be the
equivalent of a horse's saddle right and
an army of 1400 people eat from it or we
slaughter one goat and a thousand people
ate from it and then and the meat was
still there in the end that's a miracle
but all of them attended to all of them
witness all of them speak about now what
they're all either conspiring now
they're all lying or I mean that's just
like but to believe that all of these
people are conspiring you would have to
first disbelieve in every fact you've
ever heard from someone or from a group
of people or from a countless number of
people like you would have to believe
that everyone who told you that China
existed and showed you a video on
YouTube supposedly recorded in China
that they're all potentially Liars
they're all just conspiring cuz you
didn't see China yourself it's just
testimony yeah and technically why don't
you also be lie any thing you've ever
seen because you're only one person so
maybe your eyes were lying to you maybe
somebody walked past you and you inhaled
some intoxicants and you were
hallucinating
so in order to reject motivated a
concept that has been conveyed to find
that define it's it's its second eclis
diviners abundant concurrence when
there's so many concurring testimonies
at the same exact time this is the
strongest form of Reliance oh you have
like 1,400 people in the courtroom they
don't know each other or they were there
to witness and they're all saying the
same thing this man is the one who did
it right the crime or the whatever the
case they're all witnessing they say we
saw with our eyes yeah that's what it is
subhanAllah so you got the little bonus
here the person is like you got my
attention now I didn't know it was that
deep this is deep we got all of the
green beans on this side we didn't find
no red what do you do now the person's
like you got my attention where do you
want me to go now what are you saying
you talk I don't want them back
the papers to be honest a lot of time
and care and consideration for people's
resistance in our time to the concept of
fate and blind faith and the danger of
surrendering our intellect and
surrendering our will and surrendering
our agency to some you know like the
baseless notion of communications from
above the hot skies and we're aware this
was written for that seeking demanding
proof for the prophethood of Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him is
something Muslim scholars have done
forever forever why because it's a very
tall claim and so great claims require
great evidence and so this series of
papers is a reiteration of those
evidences in light of the modern mind
right the sensitivities of the modern
mind and so hopefully it can resonate
and strike a chord with those looking
for truth if you're looking for it we
are hopeful that it may tickle your
curiosity to learn where do they go to
read these papers so you can just google
them under my name you can just write
even in google your pain yaq een proofs
of prophethood approves the prophethood
series and it will come up they are six
many by the time this video comes out
the seventh will be there as well
if Allah permits we may compile them in
one place soon a book or something but
for now the website is the resource she
or he the other prisoners I don't need
no more that's enough for me I might die
tomorrow right woody what does this
prophet want for me what does God want
from me where do I go from here I'm
ready
yeah and so the greatest proof of
prophethood is actually the message of
prophethood which is the Quran and the
Quran its message in summary is that you
devote your life to the one true God
alone without any partners how through
the road map that was drawn out for you
charted for you by the one acceptances
messenger so you begin by saying I agree
I commit I recognize that there is none
worthy of worship but the ones
God the creator of the heavens and the
earth and I bear witness that Mohammed
was in fact his prophet and messenger
then it becomes a lifelong journey like
Islam is not an events entering the door
is an event and that event needs to
happen as soon as possible because
nobody guarantees tomorrow but then you
have to learn more and more and more
about this God because how can you
connect with him and devote to him until
you adore him and how can you adore him
until you refine develop amplify your
knowledge of him that's why he sent that
revelation to begin with so you learn
this Quran you study the message that
you're loving great God wanted you to
read wanted you to know sent it just for
you and then you learn more about the
life of the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him because he is the
model for the life that that God wanted
you to live the details of what devotion
looks like devotion to God in the ritual
sense in terms of you know acts of
ritualistic devotion in the spiritual
sense recognizing God living in awe of
him adoration of him all of that and
also on the surface sense that you you
worship God devote yourself to God by
serving his creation because the best of
you are those the most beloved of you to
God and the best of you are those most
beneficial to his creation that's a
lifelong process on adopting that
learning its details perfecting it as
best as we can that but that was walk
through the door first one true God I
testified none is worthy of worship but
the one true God if you're watching the
video and you're sitting at home you can
even say this and I bear witness that
Muhammad was in fact his final prophet
and message so the Arabic they would say
they don't need to say there's anything
but if they would like to say the way
the Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him said it for the sake of the
favour of that the grace of that the
blessings of that they can say ashhadu
an la ilaha illa Allah which means I
testify none is worthy of my worship but
Allah the one true God wah
ash hadu Ana Muhammadan Rasul Allah and
I bear witness that Muhammad was the
Messenger of Allah and of course belief
in Muhammad is the Messenger of Allah
he came to reaffirm and confirm the
message of all of them so it implies
belief in the rest of them anyway so
this is also just confirming what Jesus
said Moses
they all had the same message the same
mission in essence in essence yes yeah
but the same way you would have slightly
different details that you would
disclose to your children or your
company at different maturation points
likewise the details of God's message as
with the progression of the human
experience they may have developed into
different iterations in the details but
in essence it's all about surrendering
to God your that you were created for
that nice well now you're on your way to
life to living true purpose that is our
purpose that's our purpose and then
preparing preparing for what comes next
our departure date being prepared for
the Day of Judgment paradise Hellfire
now you're on your road to actual
success if you stick to it all the way
ten hundred us this life is an
examination room and then ultimately no
matter how long we live the exam has to
end and the exam paper has to get
shredded the nature of this world and
then you receive your your score and God
writes for me and for you and for all us
and see how the sinners success in this
world in the next and finally to
conclude you mentioned one time before
that this is not a blind belief but it's
a blind what surrender surrender haveá--
what does that mean that means that God
did not give you the gift of intellect
and then tell you to dismiss it for sure
it is blind in the sense that it's
inborn we all know that we have a
creator deep down inside it's like
inborn knowledge we know it same way and
we know that you love something the same
way you know that you hate something
same way that you know that you're
hungry it's not an experiment something
learned in the book it's not acquired
knowledge it's innate knowledge so the
most necessary innate fact is that we
didn't come out of nowhere we have a
creator but then I need to make sure
that the Creator is speaking here and to
verify that communication that messages
from the Creator that's where the
process of prophethood come in once I
verify then it would be illogical to try
to logic understand the logic of
it would be irrational to try to
understand up God on his rationale and
so that's why once you verify that this
is God and you have faith in him for
good reasons inborn knowledge verified
logically speaking this has to be his
message it will also be logical that you
surrender your intelligence to the
creator of your intelligence that your
wisdom inevitably is going to be
inferior to his wisdom so you blindly
surrender in that sense and that you
don't object based on what you assume is
sensibility what you assume is largely
what you assume is rationale you're
still gonna use your intellect to
understand how to apply that act of
surrender that act of dedication act of
giving to God but you're not going to
object in that sense you're surrendering
thank you so much for sharing with us I
love bless us and you and you see me
late always I mean you too thank you so
much you've gotten here much of the
evidences and proofs and it reminds me
of a beautiful statement that the truth
is hidden from one of two people the one
who turns away from it or the one is to
Prowse and don't turn away from the
truth don't be too proud break that
first Idol
usually it's that ego in a person that
now has to be broken humble yourself
before your Creator and do this homework
simply if you're still confused ask the
Creator alone for guidance ask the
Creator without any intermediaries just
you and the one who created you guide me
guide me guide me continue with that and
continue to tune in here to the Dean
show we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you
assalamualaikum